Foxconn Chairman Terry NGO has a vision
a bustling tech hub nestled among the
scenic mountains of Guam with a dynamic
population of academics and engineers
another Silicon Valley of the east part
of an Borden we sent a lot of engineers
highly skilled people here they love
this place it's temperature humidity air
it's a good place to build a high-tech
hub we Young is the only place aside
from Beijing which can call itself the
Chinese Silicon Valley with the help of
Peking University and Tsinghua
University the two universities are
partnering with Foxconn in its fourth
generation Industrial Park in Guam and
eco-friendly campus built largely with
recycled steel which will produce
smartphones large screen TVs and house a
hundred and thirty thousand square meter
R&D center as well as a big data center
housed in an energy-efficient wind
tunnel nearby China Unicom China Mobile
and China Telecom are also building
facilities go says all three will be
chipping in to build infrastructure
around the area including a fiber-optic
network by March 2015 the company
projects an animal output of five point
six billion dollars from the facility
with 12,000 workers on site now Foxconn
is touting this as their greenest and
eventually most high-tech industrial
park and it's not only the manufacturing
process that's green the glass here is
out translating and self-cleaning they
treat their wastewater on-site and even
the fruit here is tested for safety
chairman taro has said that this is a
big step moving forward unlike past
investments why probably because of most
embodies what Foxconn wants to do
eventually moving up the value chain
moving away from labor-intensive low
profit margin manufacturing working with
the country's top brain trusts to
operate at the forefront of high
technology industries eventually it goes
as he wants to service their clients at
every step of the chain from components
to consumer and perhaps one day they may
even supply clients all the way from raw
materials to final delivery of consumer
products wisely beautiful nation year
this take time maybe three to five years
and then we're gonna use
robber to make Robert or maybe Robert
making products we don't go back to
traditional with the labor you know
intensive job okay simple and then the
boring big ambitions but for a company
which has thirty production locations
across China and employs over a million
people here it's perhaps not too high a
mountain to climb
Christina Bloomberg Wien